hi my name is Neil Mueller with Google
cloud platform we're here as part of the
on-air cloud series is a series of live
webinars for Google cloud today we're
hosting two webinars my webinar on
pricing and then Sergey and team will
join me after five minutes five minutes
when I'm finished to talk about
streaming analytics also next month
something to look forward to
we'll be talking about security and IT
development tools okay without further
ado let's talk about customer friendly
GCP pricing I've got a lot of ground to
cover today but let me spend a few
minutes on why we're here we're here
because customers are really excited
about the cloud but unfortunately a
number of customers feel like they're
they're wasting money now fortunately
most of these cloud customers are not
ours and we'll talk about that in a
moment but according to right scale
which is a third-party analyst firm they
were to report called the state of the
cloud in 2017 and they said that 45% of
their cloud spen was wasted
this is self-reported waste so you want
to believe it on the left-hand side you
see the cause of a lot of this waste
we've got inflexible three-year VM
leases that are provided by other cloud
providers inflexible VM configurations
where you have to buy a certain amount
of RAM to get a certain amount of CPU
also something not on our cloud but on
every other cloud and per our billing as
opposed to what we have in here in GCP
which is per minute billing so customers
are feeling like they're wasting a lot
of money on the cloud at the same time
that they're saving a lot of money
because the cloud is much less expensive
than on-prem alternatives we're here to
give you the best of both worlds to give
you a cloud that is exactly what you
expected to pay for with customer
friendly pricing models that you can
really easily understand so this is a
summary slide we'll come to it at the
very end also if you look on the Left
we've got other cloud providers let's
consider that a baseline of a hundred
percent what you would expect to pay on
the right hand side we've got the
discounts that discount innovations that
we have here at GCP and we'll talk
through each of those so an average of
24 percent savings assisted from
sustained use discounts this is very
similar to the card that you get when
you go to your favorite sandwich shop
and if you
ten sandwiches they give you one for
free sustained use discount when you
lose it when you use a lot of GCP you
save a lot on GCP 21 percent list price
differences this is just a rack rate of
our compute if you look at the the list
price we are on average 20 percent less
than other cloud providers and I'll talk
to you a bit more in a few minutes about
why that's the case
15 percent average savings from right
sizing recommendations we recommend
within the cloud console if you're using
too much or too little compute we
recommend that you can either save money
or you should be puffy puffs beefed up
that server to make it more performant
on average if you add those numbers
together you get a 60% average discount
when you compare us to other clouds
that's a big discount all right let's
talk about all of our pricing
innovations this slide is very much a
table of contents for my talk we're
gonna start in the upper left and work
our way down to the lower right so let's
talk about list price advantages I've
talked to you about how that we get a
21% average list price reduction
compared to other clouds a sustained use
discounts the lunch counter our card up
to 24% average savings committed use
discounts up to 57% savings when you buy
instances in advance when you commit to
their use per minute billing up to 38%
savings when you pay per minute and not
per our custom machine types up to 19%
savings because you don't have to if you
need a lot of RAM and but not a lot of
CPU you can only pay for exactly what
you want we call that custom machine
types right sizing recommendations 15%
average savings we give you
recommendations on whether you you need
more CPU or more RAM preemptable VM
instances we call these PMS and we give
you an average eighteen percent savings
on workloads that can be interrupted
network service tears our newest
addition we just launched it last week
it allows you to either pick performance
or cost savings when you when you buy
your network from us cold line archival
storage at the speed of tape and the
speed of disk and the cost of tape
and lastly support we offer you the
opportunity to pay per user per month as
opposed to a flat percentage fee uplift
on your on your cloud cost okay
let's talk about why GCP is the
perennial price leader well it has a lot
to do with our volume google has a lot
of infrastructure you probably used
YouTube in Google search you may have
also used Google cloud platform we are a
very large technology company with a lot
of infrastructure we buy in bulk we
purpose build much of our infrastructure
we spent more last year than any other
cloud provider ten point nine billion in
capex in 2016
Google's vast scale means that we can
offer you more for less we also are
smart about how we build our
infrastructure on average a Google Data
Center uses 50 percent less energy than
a typical data center our PUA
which is a measure of our of our
efficiency our power usage effectiveness
is one point one to lower than any other
public cloud provider this means that we
use less energy than average if you look
at the global average of the largest
data centers in the world there are 1.7
now what this means is that about 40% of
the average energy and in a datacenter
is wasted to cooling or heating or just
general loss by comparison about 10% of
the energy and a Google Data Center is
wasted
meaning 90% of the energy that we buy
goes to providing you cloud services
we're more efficient when we run our
datacenters and we can pass the savings
on to you we're also more efficient
because we deploy very interesting
technologies like machine learning you
may have seen the article written about
deepmind who applied some of their
technology to our data center and if you
look on this graph right here time is on
the x axis on the y axis is PUA this
power use effectiveness ratio that I
told you about the closer you are to one
the better Google is closer to one than
other average data centers and when we
deploy deep Minds AI in our data center
it reduced cooling by 40% so you can
imagine what this ml looks like is we've
got let's take for example we've got
like 10 dials and each dial has 10 10
positions on it that's 10 to the 10th
power or 10 million that's a lot of
instance
is to calculate through which is exactly
what deep mind is calculating through
and finding the exact right middle
ground where we can safely operate our
data centers and also simultaneously
reduce cooling this allowed us to reduce
the cooling bill by 40 percent we're not
the only one noticing greenpeace gave us
an a other cloud providers in the space
didn't get an A we earned this as a
result of energy transparency committing
to being a hundred percent renewable by
2017 and our green advocacy that we do
we think our data centers are beautiful
inside and outside in fact this is one
of our murals that we have if you send
me a tweet and you're the first person
to send it to me I'll send you a $25
Starbucks gift card this is part of our
mural project we paint many of our data
centers with murals just ten be the
state name via Twitter and I'll send you
that gift card this is a very large data
center alright let's talk about
sustained use discounts this is the
sandwich car that I talked to you about
so if this is the neck on the x-axis
here we have the monthly average usage
and so if you use a hundred percent of
this VM for the entire month you can get
30 percent savings we're seeing our
customers experiencing an average of 24
percent average savings because many of
our customers use that VM for the entire
month in other words they're getting a
lot of free sandwiches what sustained
use provides is if you use us more we
will give you a lower price this is
automatic there's no upfront payments
required there's no lock-in and there's
no complex decision-making you don't
even have to remember the sandwich card
for us to give you the discount so it
really is just that easy you might be
wondering we use terms like customer
friendly pricing but are we really that
friendly when we're doing the
calculation of sustained use discounts I
can tell you yes we are if you look at
the graph on the lower left you can
imagine in the actual use case where
you've got a whole bunch of VMs and a
whole bunch of projects across a across
your your entire organization what we
could what we could do is we could
not be friendly about it and we could
calculate your actual usage and say that
you hadn't used a single VM the entire
month but that's not how we calculate it
what we do is we have this technology
this technique that we call inferred
instances where if you look in the
middle where we group them we group all
of the instance usage together and then
on the far right we compute a discount
based on that so we we put them together
in a way that looks like a very
successful tetris game which gives you
the maximum possible sustained use
discount truly customer friendly pricing
okay let's talk about cut committed use
discount with this but this is is when
you buy cores and memory and bulk you
can either select to use a one-year or a
three-year commitment and you can change
your machine types at any time if you do
this with us for one year or for three
years we'll give you up to a fifty seven
percent discount big discount so what
you're doing here is you're buying cores
in memory in bulk if you buy for one
year it's a thirty seven percent savings
if you buy it for three years it's a
fifty seven percent savings if you
compare this to other similar offerings
in the cloud space for example AWS is
reserved instances this is again a
report from a company called RightScale
they're a third party advisory firm out
there and this is a report that they did
very recently in March when we released
committed use discounts we are the blue
block in this case lower is better
because we're talking about price and
costs so because of the digit rigidity
of the AWS our eyes and the flexibility
of the committed use discounts the
realized benefit for you is much higher
in this case the costs are much lower
okay let's get into a bit more detail
about committed use discounts like I
said these available in one and three
year you commit to a certain number of V
CPUs and a certain amount of memory this
is valid for any Google cloud compute
engine or gke non shared core VMs and
it's ideal for predictable steady-state
workloads
I said that it's a committed use on CPU
and also memory there are very flexible
limits on the ratio between memory and
CPU so anything from 0.9 gigabits of RAM
up to 6.5 gigabits of RAM per CPU
inclusive those two numbers is an
appropriate ratio so if you've got a
very memory intensive application that
doesn't require much CPU committed use
discounts it's still gonna be good for
you the disk out supplied to aggregate
regional usage for example all of your
Restall of usage in Iowa or Oregon or
London okay this is a summary slide
talking about committed use discounts
what I want to highlight here is the
very far right block which says that in
order to attain these deep discounts
without upfront payment in order you can
attain these deep discounts without
upfront payments at all because we don't
require you to do any upfront payments
this is very different from other
reserved instance type structures that
you see there in the cloud per minute
billing okay so I'm DCP you only pay for
what you use so for example if you're
using a VM for only 11 minutes you're
gonna pay for 11 minutes not 60 minutes
this is a big differentiator with other
from other cloud providers let's walk
through a short example so on the right
here you see that if you're using the
the virtual machine for between 12 and
25 minutes your average savings is up to
38 percent custom machine types if you
go with another cloud provider you will
be dictated a certain amount of CPU and
memory and if you need more CPU or less
CPU you have to pay for the stuff that
you don't use so right here on the
x-axis you've got a series of machines
and the gray would be waste in this case
on GCP the the waste would be much much
less on average we're seeing customers
save up to 19 percent when they use
custom machine types this is a
screenshot that I took from the user
interface we've got these dials where
you can dial up the amount of cores or
the amount of memory that you want and
we did the math and it turns out that
there's 690
different compute types if you compare
that to other cloud providers we have a
hundred and ten more compute types than
they do so it really is you know you get
exactly what you want and and nothing
more right sizing recommendations this
is very similar to custom machine types
what this looks like in the user
interface is a recommendation where it
says hey you're using a bit more
instance compute then you have purchased
would you like to upgrade or in more
cases than that you have purchased an
instance type that is larger than you
need and you're paying for something
that you're not using would you like to
save yourself a little money and all you
have to do is click the button right
here to either dismiss all those
recommendations or to learn more and
with one click you can activate them
it's the opposite of requiring you to
plan in advance for demand that you
can't possibly forecast 25% of of
monitored instances get a recommendation
on average so that's a lot it'll be a
good portion of your instances now you
can very easily dismiss these or or take
action recommendations take take a look
at CPU and memory on average we're
seeing 60% of those recommendations
offering to save you money and 40%
offering to increase your instance size
to give it absolutely suggest that you
get a big a beefier instance because
you're getting a more traffic than you
then you may have expected if you use
stack driver the the the granularity of
these recommendations improves quite a
bit let's talk about preemptable machine
types preemptable machine types are very
good for workloads such as batch or
scientific predictable workloads that
you don't think we're going to go down
they're exactly like regular VMs except
for they are eighty percent less
expensive they can run for a maximum of
24 hours at which time they'll be shut
down
you can terminate them earlier if you
like and it offers predictable billing
compared to other cloud providers that
have similar structures like this but
they're based on marketplaces where you
would have to hire somebody to go into
that
marketplace and understand the flow
price of that machine instance whereas
here it's just a flat 80% off so much
easier to forecast we view this as you
know customer friendly pricing like I
said they're very good for various kinds
of workloads that you know might be able
to be interrupted for example batch jobs
pipeline builds after I was processing
big data workloads analytics media
encoding scientific work financial
modeling devtest crawling that kind of
workloads what is most amazing about
PDMS is how easy they are to deploy I
mentioned with other types of structures
like this from other cloud providers you
might need to hire somebody to go in
there and understand the marketplace
dynamics of their instance of their
interruptible instances not with ours
they are a flat 80% price reduction and
you can either activate it using this
code right here that I've got on the
screen or in the cloud console with a
point-and-click customers love these for
example Mark Johnson the founder of
Descartes Labs has been able to predict
corn yield more accurately than the
United States Department of Agriculture
all using P VMs so he's benefiting from
GCP at 80% the cost and producing
incredible output for his customers
network service tiers last week we
became the first major public cloud to
offer a tiered cloud network what this
means for you is that you can either
choose to pick performance which we call
the premium tier think premium gasoline
if you pick the premium tier it is on
average 70% faster than other cloud
networks it is 14 to 80 percent more
expensive than other competing clouds
and so the ratio of 18 percent more for
70% more power that's a that's a very
good ratio we feel like it's a good
value for your money if you pick premium
you're riding on the Google Network
which is a non circuitous direct private
dedicated path from your cloud workloads
to your end customers aggressing out of
a pop very near to your end customers
if you choose standard you'll benefit
from a six to nine percent savings over
other competing clouds standard Network
uses the public internet which is very
similar to what other public clouds I
will provide you this is often not a
direct path it suffers from lower
security lower reliability but it it's a
very good value for the money let's talk
about storage on this graph on the
x-axis you see the retrieval frequency
so on the left you've got Glacier an AWS
product that offers written retrieval
frequency of three to five hours it is
very close to the same price as GCS cold
line which offers millisecond access
time we also offer a near line regional
and GCS multi-regional the reason we've
put there of storage options next to
ours is what you'll notice is hours are
always below theirs which means that we
are less expensive for their retrieval
time required so we think that our
storage is going to be a better value
for online data whether it's hot or cold
whether you've got millisecond access
time that you need globally reliable or
or less cold line is a highly available
affordable solution for backup archival
and disaster recovery it really is
incredible we offer you the speed of
discs at the cost of tape but you might
be asking yourself how am I going to get
all my data up into the cloud well for
that we just launched something about
last month called the transfer appliance
this is a physical appliance that we
rent you for a window of time you load
your data onto it and then you send it
back to us using a courier the capacity
for this is up to one peda bit
compressed it's the largest transfer
appliance in the cloud because a lot of
our customers are moving a lot of data
to us and we wanted to give them as much
capacity as we possibly could the
transfer appliance is all about speed in
this animation what you're seeing is how
fast it would take a transfer appliance
to be shipped out to you for you
fill it up and for you to send it back
to us and ice to load it into Google
Cloud storage on average 43 days if you
compare that over a typical Network
which is 100 megabits per second it is
going to take a lot longer than 43 days
as you can see it'll take multiple years
pick more than three years let's talk
about what we're doing for support
support hasn't evolved what we are doing
to evolve it is we're offering role
based support what this means is that
you pay a flat price per user per month
as opposed to a percentage fee uplift on
your cloud usage so you might be
accustomed to paying a certain
percentage like 10 to 20 to 30 percent
uplift on your cloud usage we are
evolving that to this new method where
you pay a flat fee per user per month so
let's take an example let's say that
you're a development shop with 10
engineers that would be 10 engineers
multiplied by $100 per user per month
multiplied by 12 so that's $12,000 in
annual support for this development shop
which is likely much much less and
certainly much much more predictable
than if you were to pay a flat
percentage fee on your on your cloud
bill it also is a lot closer to getting
a value for your money because we're
charging you per engineer as opposed to
charging you a percentage uplift the old
model we call a count based the new
model we call role based account based
you're accustomed to long-term contracts
standardized tiers and like I said
percentage based uplift on your cloud
bill with role base you've got a very
flexible environment that you can change
month to month no commitments very
customizable configurations you tell us
how many users you want and it's very
predictable because you know how many
users you're buying this is coming very
soon and we're incredibly excited about
it
it offers development support production
support and also support for your
business critical apps
alright let's talk about some key
takeaways if we start on the upper left
we talked about why Google was a
perennial price leader we operated at a
vast scale and we passed those benefits
on to you on average were 20% less than
other cloud providers just the rack rate
sustained used discounts just like when
you go into a sandwich shop this is up
to 24% average savings committed use
discounts if you are able to plan ahead
and know that you're going to use us we
don't make you pay up front but we offer
you up to 57 percent savings for a
three-year contract per minute billing
up to 38 percent savings by paying by
the minute as opposed to paying by the
hour the analogy I gave the example I
gave was using 11 minutes and paying for
60 very frustrating we don't consider
that customer friendly pricing and so we
don't make you do it custom machine
types up to 19 percent average savings
when you pick any configuration of CPU
and RAM right sizing recommendations 15
percent average savings by auto-scaling
compute around your needs we give you
these recommendations 60% of the time
they're to reduce the size of the
workload offering you a savings 40
percent of the time on average there for
you to beef up your instance and save
you downtime preemptable VM instances up
to 80 % savings and this is a flat fee
not based on a market place up to 80%
savings on workloads it can be
interrupted like batch jobs or crawling
or scientific work network service tears
our newest member to this list where you
can pick performance and get 70% higher
performance than the average cloud
provider or savings and save 9 percent
compared to other clouds cold line
archival storage and the transfer
appliance which allows you to move lots
of data to the cloud very quickly
support we are evolving support and very
excited about it with roll based support
customers pay a flat monthly fee per
user per engineer here's that graph
again let's talk about where we where
we've come so another cloud provider on
the Left will charge you a baseline of a
hundred percent
you can experience an average of 60%
savings for compute workloads on GCP 24
percent is coming from sustained use
discounts 21 percent from list price dis
discounts 15 percent from right sides
and recommendations big benefits for you
customers are picking GCP in part
because of our customer friendly pricing
but also for a lot of other reasons on
the Left we offer you true cloud
economics that's all about the pricing
we've walked through a number of
examples where we provide you very
transparent friendly pricing structures
that you can without taking a lot of
time take advantage of most of these you
take advantage of just by using the
system at all you don't have to plan
ahead we offer you future proof
infrastructure where you can scale your
business smoothy and responsibly for
example where the first cloud to offer
Silverlake Intel chips and you didn't
have to plan for that you didn't have to
you know buy them a couple of years ago
you can buy them the second that you
want them and then the second you stop
wanting to use them you can stop paying
for them big advantages that you get
from using the cloud you can also get
access to incredible innovation Google
is known for our interface artificial
intelligence and machine learning we
give you access to many of our API s
including vision API natural language
API bigquery you can use these to really
spark off a lot of innovation at your
company and Google grade security we
offer multiple layers of security so
that you can control your cloud from
chip to chiller ok with that I think
I've been told that we've got a couple
of questions that I probably should help
answer
you
okay I'm back I can see on my screen
here that we've got five questions to
answer the first one is where did the
idea for sustained use discounts come
from it predates me here at Google I
came up with a lunch counter example
because I eat sandwiches and when I buy
ten of them I get a free sandwich and it
sounds a lot like sustained use
discounts the big difference between
sustained use discounts and the lunch
counter is that I'm always forgetting my
little card and losing it and that never
happens because we keep track of it for
you question to our DCP pricing
innovations only for compute many of
them are for compute right sizing
recommendations sustained use discount
committed use discount those are for
compute however many of them are not for
example cold line where we offer you the
speed of disk at the cost of tape is
very innovative and as a storage
innovation not a computer innovation
network service tears also is the
opportunity for you to experience 70%
faster networks than the average cloud
provider or nine percent lower costs and
that's a networking innovation question
number three can I change my instance
sizes and still receive committed use
discounts yes
unlike other cloud providers that offer
you committed use discount structures
that are inflexible hours are flexible
so you buy a certain amount of CPU and a
certain amount of memory and within that
bundle that basket you can change
exactly the kind of VM configurations
that you want from minutes a minute day
to day within that within that month
within that year whether you whether
it's a one-year or a three-year
committed use discount the question for
what is the difference between suds and
cuts sustained use discount let's see if
I can think of a funny analogy a
sustained use discount is when you go to
the lunch counter and they give you one
of those cards and if you eat 10 of
those sandwiches they give you a free
sandwich committed use discounts is when
you go to the car wash and you say I
want to buy 10 car
I'm gonna buy them right now and then
I'm gonna use them over the next one
year or three year and as a result you
you get you know a cheaper rate per
carwash the big didn't that analogy
falls apart a little bit because we
don't make you pay ahead and the carwash
would but other than that it's a decent
analogy number five well right sizing
recommendations support all operating
system compute instance types not just
Linux but Windows servers as well yes it
supports all of the instances that we
have I use it on mine and it gives me
recommendations for some reason for mine
it's always telling me to make them
smaller it never tells me to make them
bigger maybe it's because I don't run
that many popular websites hopefully you
you do and it works on on all of mine
Linux and windows are there any more
questions guys okay thank you so much
for your time please stick around our
next webinar is on streaming analytics
very exciting Sergey and team will be
here to talk you through that next month
also we've got another on-air webinar
series by Google cloud it's on security
and IT development tools ok for now
thank you so much your help
you